bonsoir nous ce soir monsieur françois
hollande du parti socialiste de la
corrèze où vous présenter dans ce
département en deuxième position sur la
liste des législatives en 81 vous avez
été battu par jacques chirac aux
élections législatives et en 83 par
contre vous avez obtenu un siège de
conseiller municipal à ussel alors je
reviens très brièvement sur l'élection
de 80 qu'est ce qui peut faire courir un
candidat socialiste en haute corrèze où
jacques chirac est très très implanté et
vous soyez une maxime qui dit il n'ya
pas besoin d'espérer pour entreprendre
ni de réussir pour persévérer
alors j'en suis là c'est pas parce que
on fait la politique on doit forcément
avoir une ambition immédiate fait la
politique aussi pour porter quelques
idées mes idées sont connus ce sont les
idées du parti socialiste et moi je suis
en corrèze pour représenter ce parti ses
idées et réflexions qu'il défend auprès
de tous ceux qui habitent cette terre
qui n'est la propriété de personne pas
plus de jacques chirac que d'aucun autre
oui vous avez été directeur de cabinet
de max gallo un temps où il était porte
parole du gouvernement alors on peut
supposer qu'un énarque com et vous
jeunes et quelques ambitions alors vos
camarades du ps il vous balance si j'ose
dire dans un fief chiraquien en sachant
pertinemment que vous allez perdre entre
gentils fanon ici c'est très gentil bon
parce que j'étais pas été balancés en
eau de quoi je me suis balancée moi-même
et deuxièmement vous avez dit que
j'étais jeune donc j'ai tout le temps
devant moi et il n'ya pas besoin d'être
forcément pressés pour faire la
présidente en marmonnant de dire que
vous êtes conseiller aussi à la cour des
comptes vous êtes responsable d'une
rubrique économique dans un quotidien
national
enfin bref on a l'impression que le ps
présente une carte de visite en omettant
comme ça sur sa liste vous êtes une
carte de visite d'abord avoir une carte
de visite c'est ni bien ni mal ça donne
une caractéristique à quelqu'un
maintenant ça ne suffit pas c'est pas
parce qu'on a des diplômes faire des
études c'est d'abord une chance donc
ça ne confère aucun droit c'est pas
parce qu'on a des diplômes qu'on a
quelques titres à à faire valoir en
matière politique je crois que je suis
en haute corrèze je suis candidat du
parti socialiste non pas en fonction de
ma carte de visite mais en fonction des
qualités que mes amis socialistes ou les
électeurs voudront bien me reconnaître
des relents ont déjà reconnu il vous
voulez prouver que vous êtes un homme de
terrain vous savez que en corrèze a tout
de même 30 % de personnes qui sont des
ouvriers
il ya des normes trop d'hommes dans des
entreprises et notamment par exemple la
peau mais leur électrique alors on a vu
le ps se remuer le député casal à paris
en décembre
et puis les gens à pommerit sont
toujours au même point alors vous faites
rien finalement
là vous avez une position qui est pensé
que la politique ou que l'état ou que le
pouvoir peut tout faire en matière
d'entreprises matière elle suit c'est
pas si simple principe bien placé pour
défendre leur cause
on n'est pas forcément efficace parce
que on est bien placé on est efficace
parce qu'on répond concrètement à une
véritable situation vous avez parlé de
la pomelle réalité il y a un problème
industriel il ya un problème de reprise
de cette entreprise il ya aussi un
problème faut bien le dire syndicale
dans cette entrevue ce qui a joué dans
le conflit qui a pu se produire dans
cette entreprise est bien qu'à saintes
député de la corrèze a fait son travail
il a défendu le dossier mais qu'à saint
n'est pas chef d'entreprise il peut pas
reprendre à lui tout seul la peau malgré
électrique donc il faut que le pouvoir
fasse ce qu'il doive ce qu'il a à faire
ce qui a procuré des subventions aider à
la reprise lorsque celle ci se présente
mais le pouvoir ne peut pas se
transformer en gestionnaires
d'entreprises je crois qu'il faut en
corrèze comme ailleurs avoir bien le
sentiment de qui est compétent pour
quelles actions il est certain que les
chefs d'entreprises sont aujourd'hui
comme avant
compétent en matière d'emploi et un
panneau ce temps que fait le ps
corréziens pour reprendre la question
sous une autre forme et on entend
surtout parler du rpr et du parti
communiste sont les deux blocs qui
s'affrontent
1depuis depuis longtemps et le ps
un peu discret si j'ose dire dans cette
affaire je schématise bien entendu
essayé d'être le moins discret possible
donc je crois qu'il faut pas non plus
caricaturer les choses vous avez raison
lorsque vous dites que pendant un
certain temps il ya eu un débat en
corrèze à débat politique orientée entre
le parti communiste entre par le rpr de
notre côté je crois que c'est en train
de changer
parti socialiste je les vieux en haute
corrèze a progressé le parti communiste
a régressé la droite maintient pour
l'instant ses positions mais nous
espérons l'entamé donc je crois que ces
espèces de dialogue obligé qu'il y avait
un autre parti communiste et et leur
père tente à a laissé place à ce que on
appelle à plus le trial og c'est à dire
qu'il ya un troisième partenaire qui est
le parti socialiste et je crois que
maintenant le parti socialiste est
devenu le premier parti à gauche en
corrèze en corrèze avant mais le pc
corréziens qui est un pc dur ne vous
fait pas de cadeau ou enquêtes sont vos
rapports avec les écouter nous avons des
rapports de concurrents puisque nous
présentons séparés à des élections mais
nous n'avons pas des rapports
d'adversaires notre adversaire c'est la
droite notre concurrent à gauche c de
l'article 17 passes qui apparaît dans
les discos a mais qu'il y ait défense et
illustration de notre bilan est mise en
cause du parti communiste parce qu'ils
s'écartent de l'union de la gauche ça ça
ne paraît être la nature même du débat
politique que le parti communiste s'en
prennent la politique du gouvernement
c'est aussi son droit et il reste que
nous sommes deux formations qui avons
été unis à un moment qui n'est plus
aujourd'hui et qui avons un rapport de
concurrence normale et les électeurs
choisiront le parti de gauche qui
remplit le mieux leur inspiration je
crois que c'est plutôt le parti
socialiste mais faute d'accord les
corréziens 2
comprendre une salade électorale parce
que finalement lorsque vous êtes au
conseil régional dans les conseils
généraux dans les mairies les alliés les
amis c'est le ps et le pc et puis arrive
une élection est pas vous auriez tout à
la figure alors ça pour comprendre c'est
un peu dur non je crois que ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que à l'échelon
national a vu le parti communiste a fait
le choix de quitter le gouvernement en
juillet 1984 et de plus associé à la
politique censée mener se sont plaints
d'un soir le gouvernement
donc le particulier s'est dissocié de la
gestion nationale maintenant au niveau
local il n'a pour l'instant on put
aucune alliance au conseil rural vous
avez parlé
le particulier se fait partie de la
majorité régionale soutient ils votent
le budget et l'action des sociétés on
s'entend sans régional alors on s'entend
il se peut qu'il y ait dans certains cas
des unions qui soient formées à
l'échelon local au national
et puis qu'on soit pas d'accord sur le
plot dick cheney il vaut mieux qu'on ait
cette clarté lattes que si vous voulez
la confusion de la droite qui ne
s'entend me semble-t-il pas au niveau
national on l'a bien vu avec la dernière
affaire d'ars et qui ne paraît pas sans
dents au niveau local puisqu'il y a
aussi plusieurs listes à droite note à
tous les choses restent en nous qui nous
apporte c'est que le parti l'espace que
plus de voix possible et finalement n'ai
pas besoin de trouver forcément d'autres
alliés restent en politique vous êtes
conseil municipal doit il seul dans le
maire et le docteur bellecour il est
dans l'opposition nationale alors pour
vous c'est déjà un début de cohabitation
sa annoncé le scrutin qui fait que
aujourd'hui on est avocat habiter avec
dr bell plus aux geckos ebit au sens où
je suis au lit avec le docteur bécaud
qu'il essaye de l'être avec moi j'espère
ça vous aurez d'accord ça nous arrive
est d'accord ça nous arrive de plus
souvent de ne pas être d'accord et je le
regrette quelquefois lorsque nous
proposons des choses qui pourraient
aller dans le bon sens pour ussel mais
là c'est vous avez raison de faire cette
comparaison c'est une cohabitation
institutionnels y ait eu un scrutin il
ya une minorité il ya une majorité les
choses sont claires on peut néanmoins
avoir des rapports courtois et normaux
avec des hommes qui siège dans l'ordre
et des femmes qui siègent dans le même
conseil municipal que nous laissons la
politique de côté revenons-en à
l'économie
avec eux on dit que pour développer
l'économie de limousine il faudrait déjà
commencer par désenclaver le les moyens
d un moment que
socialistes ont des relais vers le
pouvoir et ceux d enclavement on
l'attend apparemment toujours qu'est ce
que vous allez faire pour des enfants
c'est le désenclavement c'est une
opération vaste il s'agit de permettre
des liaisons plus facile entre la
corrèze de lille elle reste du
territoire donc contrat visant sa vie il
s'agit de grandes infrastructures déjà
il ya eu des choses de fake nationale 89
qui a une meilleure liaison avec le lot
et c'est celle en scellant je l'entends
bien puisque ce sont des travaux coûteux
et de grande ampleur mais je reprends ce
que vous avez dit c'est pas simplement
le désenclavement le développement
économique c'est à dire que bien sûr ça
passe par des liaisons plus facile mais
ça passe aussi par un esprit
d'entreprise par une action de formation
professionnelle par une action de
conseil aux entreprises partenaires au
développement du tissu local
toute chose qui effectivement mettront
peut-être moins de temps que le
désagrément qui doivent l'accompagner
je crois qu'il ya pas une action
miraculeux qui a pas une théorie
économique fantastique
il ya simplement une ensemble d'actions
qui permettent sur le terrain trouver
des solutions une dernière question en
ce moment vous avez écrit un livre
collectif la gauche bouge et jean peu
près ne vous attaque c'est à ce moment
là d'être un peu trop sensible un peu
trop proche du mrp
qu'est ce que vous en pensez là je pense
d'abord que très rapidement au sein des
partis se disent y ait un vrai débat
on a des positions quelquefois divergent
mais on se rassemble sur le même
objectif qui est un objectif de justice
et de progrès jean poperen à penser que
les tests que nous émettions été les
thèses qui allait à peu trop dans un
certain sens on lui a répondu je crois
que c'est à l'honneur notre particulier
ce débat en notre sein je vous remercie
demain l'invité sera assurément la peau
du parti communiste va creuser